This was Nikki Haley
nearly two years ago on the poss
of running
against Donald Trump for preside
once again in 20, 24.
Will you support him? Yes.
I would not run if President Tru
And this was Nikki Haley,
just two weeks ago.
On the possibility of running
against Donald Trump for Preside
Yes, we need to go in a new dire
And can I be that later?
Yes.
I think it's time
for new generational change.
I don't think you need to be 80
old to go be a leader in D.C.
How things have changed.
In just over a week,
the former Trump
administration ambassador
to the United Nations
is expected to announce
that she'll battle her former bo
for the Republican nomination.
She'll be the first,
but definitely not the last
to mount a challenge to Trump.
Let's just say
he isn't too happy about it.
You know, she
said numerous times,
I put it up actually
that I would never run above
president runs.
He was a great president, etc.,
She said that numerous times.
But she's a very ambitious perso
and she just couldn't stay in a
I said, You know what?
If you want to run, you go ahead
Nikki suffers
from something
that's a very tough thing to suf
She's overly ambitious
No surprises there.
Trump starts with the very
the very first thing he starts w
I guess, a kind of gender trope
about the overly ambitious woman
And you better believe that
Nikki Haley,
who is
pretty used
to running against a lot of men,
that's something
that she's going to exploit.
But what's her path really here
in this race?
You know,
that's a big question
for Nikki Haley, who when she wa
the Trump
administration, had pretty high
approval ratings.
She got approval ratings
that were fairly good
from Democrats and Republicans.
But how did she gather enough mo
and steam with a primary audienc
when it's all about her
and it's all about the gut,
like how does she grab those fol
It's not going to be
this sort of intellectual,
generational argument that says,
you know,
I'm not 80, I'm only 50 or whoev
she is.
So, I mean,
I think she's got some real work
Like,
what is the Nikki Haley constitu
and how is she going
to answer the questions
about
what she said
a year ago
about not running against Trump,
about working for Trump?
There's been a lot of back
and forth on Trump from Nikki Ha
So if you actually look after
January six, Nikki Haley
basically said
I think Donald Trump has done.
He's he went as far down as he c
There's no coming back for him.
And then as the political tide
started showing
that Trump was making a resurrec
with the Republican base,
Nikki Haley changed her tune.
So this is not the first time
that she's sort of
flipped on Donald Trump.
But you have House Republicans
already starting
to call her out for that.
And you know that they're going
to be attacking her
for what they call flip flopping
I talked to Max Miller last week
and he said people continue to b
President Trump
only to elevate their platform.
And he pointed to Nikki Haley.
And he pointed to Mike Pompeo.
And those are both
people who used to work for Trum
And Miller,
I would
add, is a former senior adviser
Yeah, I guess.
And to his point,
she's not alone
in the Flip-Flopping from here.
I mean, she would not be alone.
But there is some
brand new reporting out this mor
at CNN New York Times as well
about Americans for Prosperity.
This is the Koch organization.
They are saying
that to write a new chapter
for our country,
we need to turn the page on the
So the best thing for the countr
would be to have a president in
who represents a new chapter.
They are saying they are going t
on the
in the primary, the Republican p
They're going to pick
a horse in that race
and that horse
is not going to be Donald Trump.
That's a pretty extraordinary mo
from an organization
that could rival the RNC
in terms of funds and resources.
Yeah, the Kochs,
they stayed out of the 20,
20 presidential race.
They stayed out of the 2016
presidential race.
There's no love lost between the
and Trump and Trump world
They think that Trump has taken
in the wrong direction.
And so the fact that they're goi
to potentially
put their money behind
and potentially a lot of money
behind another candidate
could shake up the race in a maj
I would expect a number of these
other potential candidates
people like Ron DeSantis
who the Kochs backed in 2018 to
hat in
hand to the Kochs
and saying that I am
the person who can take on Trump
And there's been a big challenge
among the Republicans
about whether or not
you should have one person
take on Trump one on one
or whether or not
you're going to have a big field
This could put things in the dir
of having one person
with a lot of money behind them
as a potential challenger.
And I think that the key on this
is for the last since 20, 15,
it has always been all right, fi
Are you just going to sit there
and wait for him to go away? Rig
Or somebody's
going to actually take action
to do something about it.
And let me everyone has chosen t
always and has always
been wrong about that.
And this is the first signal
of like actual real money
coming in and trying to push the
to your to your very point.
McKay Coppins writes a piece thi
on the Republicans
20, 24 magical
thinking that faced
with the prospect
of another cycle dominated by Tr
and uncertainty
that he can actually be beaten
in the primaries,
Republicans are quietly rooting
for some things out there
that will make him go away.
And they would strongly prefer
not to be the ones
to make it happen themselves.
He also writes in this piece
that Republicans that he talked
for this story
are basically whispering that
you know, Trump
in old age will just
go away, pass away, literally.
I mean, Republicans are telling
Yeah,
that is I mean, if not magical,
I don't know what I
hope is not a strategy.
I mean, listen, Trump is either
sort of like 25% or 55% of the
Republican electorate.
Maybe it's something like 35%
if you sort of average it out.
You know, the idea is,
you know, he's a balloon,
not a Chinese
by balloon, but a balloon that's
sort of lose altitude right
as time goes on
because of the weight of his own
you know, meeting with anti-Semi
or the investigations
that are going on
or, you know, the strength of so
like Ron DeSantis,
who is in a really good position
He's, you know, maybe he's got 2
or 20% of the electorate,
Republican electorate.
He can grow. Right.
And the idea is,
can you just wait and hope passi
that this person,
Donald Trump,
who has such a strong
hold on the Republican electorat
just fade away?
The lesson from 2016 seems to be
I mean, just take a listen
to what it was like to run again
back then.
I don't even know why I mentione
You know,
what happens is this look, it's
It's very sad.
His family is so ashamed
in the case of lying Ted Cruz ly
lies. Oh, he lies.
Now you look at Kasich.
I have never seen
a human being eight
in such a disgusting fashion guy
like Rubio is a baby
it's Rubio
you know, watching that
there are two things about that.
Trump goes on the offensive.
He picks off his opponents one b
But the other thing
I think there is really a questi
of the energy that you see in th
from those years ago.
You don't see that
same kind of energy from Trump t
I think it's an open question. Y
If you talk to the people in Tru
they say they have
got a lot of time
to ramp up that energy
to do the kind of rallies that h
and he was famous for in 20,
16 and 20, 20 but he is older.
He does have
a lot of political battles behin
He if you talk to people close t
is more bitter,
not only about 20, 20,
but about the fact that people l
Nikki Haley
and people that he thought were
his supporters have turned again
and people
that he endorsed like Ron
DeSantis are potentially
running against him.
And so he is in a position
where he doesn't have that same
that same likeness that he had i
And that may make it difficult f
And there was also no sort of sh
value back then in watching him.
We've seen this movie before
in an entertainment.
I mean
this is like funny to watch and
it was interesting to watch on T
and now it's tired. Yeah, it's o
And I think the calculation righ
to some degree is,
you know, the 25 to 30%
that's baked in for him.
Everybody gets that.
What he doesn't have anymore is
skeptical folks
who are willing to just say, oka
And so can they all coalesce
together behind a single
or a couple of candidates to put
in real problematic territory
in a primary.
And I think that's the open ques
right now.
Meanwhile, if you're Ron DeSanti
you're just not saying anything
No.
And I mean, Republicans
think that dissenters is playing
Right.
He hasn't announced
he hasn't really signaled
that he was going to launch his
soon.
And we're already talking about
as the number one heavyweight
going against Donald Trump.
Though
DeSantis is in a very strong pla
he's trying to not alienate Trum
supporters,
but he's also making a punch her
and there, you know, saying, loo
I won reelection
So he's he's having his say.
But I think that
one of the attacks
that Trump is also doing
is he's trying to say that
DeSantis is beholden to special
and to quote the deep state
because he doesn't have his own
independent money.
So Trump is trying to find
what works against
it is already he's still feeling